hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking method today I'm going to be
showing you how I made 1.1 mil and about
50 minutes so just under an hour uh now
this method cannot be done hourly per se
like you can't do it over and over and
over again um but it's a very lowrisk
way to get about 1.1 mil um the items
take a day or two to buy um but no skill
requirements at all all you need is a
little bit money and uh you can do it on
level three account so I'll how to do it
and let's go okay so what we're going to
be doing today is we're going to be
making super compost by using compost
potions on regular compost now this was
at the suggestion of someone in the clan
chat so thank you very much this is an
awesome way to make money you know who
you are so yeah thanks again and what
we're going to be doing is um you use
each individual compost potion dose on a
regular compost and it turns into a
super compost um so we bought these over
the course of a day and a half probably
cuz the limit on them is only 5050 so it
does take a while to buy um but it's
kind of good in some ways because it
kind of creates a bottleneck on the item
so there's still thousands of these
traded every hour so someone's not going
to hoard all the compost it'll take a
while to buy for everyone um but once
you do have them very easy way to make
some quick cash it's not very risky
either because as soon as you buy the
compost potion I bought it for the high
price even um you can use it right away
and you won't lose any money you'll
definitely make money so it's not like
you're kind of doing a risky Flip or
anything it's pretty safe so yeah what
we're going to do is withdraw five of
the compost potions from your bank and
then you're can just individually use
them on the regular compost uh which
will then turn into a Super
compost um this isn't the most efficient
method I'll come back in a bit and show
you what I find to be the easiest um but
yeah we'll do this for a while and I'll
see you in a minute okay so I've done
this for about half an hour now um so I
found this is the easiest method you're
going to withdraw the five compost
potions the rest compost and then you're
going to drag it down to the bottom
right corner you're going to spam click
them together making sure you hit these
compost first or the regular compost
sorry then it's going to fly off to
another spot you're going to drag it
back down to that spot spam click them
together again making sure you hit the
compost first and do it one more time
and then that's pretty much it that's
full inventory it's definitely not the
most efficient way so if you guys find
an easier way definitely leave a comment
um but this is the easiest way I found
in doing this I can get about 600 done
in an hour so a little bit more than
what we have so hopefully this will only
take me about 15 minutes or so um but
again yeah so you're going to drag it
down there SP SP click them together
it's going to fly off to another spot
it's going to drag it back down again uh
spam click them together and uh that's
it guys so we'll see how many we can get
done in the hour and I'll come back when
we are done okay so we're just doing the
last inventory here we kind of shifted
over to the other side just cuz kind of
made my hand hurt a little less so yes
this method is very very
tedious um and if you focus on it too
much it it kind of hurts your hand but
anyway it's totally worth it because you
get a good amount of profit from this so
that was the last inventory um we draw
2K super compost cuz that's how many we
should get from 500 potions uh I guess
we had seven left over or something so
we draw the 2K and now we get to see how
much we can actually sell it for okay so
we're going to start by buying a super
compost just to see what the price is at
now um how the super combat super
compost uh so we'll instantly buy it
for uh 97 coins and uh which is a little
bit lower than what it was before and
can't quite inst sell it um um so yeah
it does vary a little bit on what the
price of Super compost is at but I mean
you're always going to make decent
amount of money from this so 857 so it's
about 100K difference in what we sell it
for the higher price or the low price so
we sell it for the high price we'll get
about 1.2 mil and for the low price
we'll get 1.1 mil um so we'll pop it in
for the high price for now but kind of
in a bit of a time limit here I got to
go work so um I might end up selling it
for the low price but you can see if
you're patient you get an extra 100K or
so and yeah we'll come back when uh the
stuff has sold
okay so the super compost have sold um
you notice we did sell it for the low
price so we did lose 100K there uh but
in total we'll still calculate how much
we managed to make so we'll claim the
super compost and um just to be aware we
bought the compost potions for 550k and
the compost for about 50k so we spent
600k on the ingredients for this and we
got 1.7 mil pack from combining them
into Super compost honestly took 20
minutes to sell at the low price um so
minus that we're going to get about 1.1
mil no requirements for this method you
just need about 500k starting cash and
yeah requires a little bit of patience
it'll take a day or two for the super
compost to buy enough to do for an hour
but honestly you don't want to do this
for three hours straight it's really
boring anyway so I hope you guys enjoyed
um again if you're enjoying the channel
remember to hit that subscribe button
for more methods in the future and I'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
n